how many young young boys do you think
you had fun with
oh
well there's a note saying as many dicks
they were put in me if they were
sticking out i'd look like a porky fine
that's how many
all right frankie yes sir frankie uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally
cleveland ohio and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were young
yes how did you describe your childhood
um
exciting for a person who
knew he was gay at the age of 11 or 12
in a time when it wasn't right
and i had a
let's start the story i had a mother
who had a boyfriend while my father was
alive but i don't think my father cared
because he was like 24 years older than
my mother
when my mother used to go with her
boyfriend i used to lay next to her
while he was having
sex with my mother and i quite didn't
know what all that was about
until i got older and
started hearing sounds that i heard when
i was a kid
then when i got older about 11 or 12
i started paying for guys
in my school five dollars here eight
dollars there
and one of the guys told me and
i think i was the very first sex
offender to ever be arrested
for that matter of fact i had to never
forget it a black judge her last name
was kennedy
this is in cleveland ohio i was in the
papers front page
cleveland press on the cleveland plain
dealer
i'm still sure if you looked in the
archives i'd be there
anyway judge gave me
a year probation i had to spend two
years two summers
and on an amish farm
that was my sentence and i was thinking
i was 11 or 12.
and then nothing happened
until i got into my 30s
and a hustler came up to me and he was
like 16 years old
and i
paid it and i paid the price
i did five years house arrest
and all that good stuff a group and
everything
and then about
four or five in 2003
i picked up a gentleman i came home from
the bar a little drunk
hi he was 13.
i guess i really wasn't looking at age
i didn't ask how old he was took him
home
well there was a whole thing before that
he he lied to me he told me that he
was waiting for his brother to pick him
up from tarpon springs and
this and that and so i took him home i
said well why don't you stay at my place
one thing led to another dirty movie
and then sex then i found out the next
day when he knocked down my door after
school
that he told me if you don't buy me a
carton of cigarettes i'm going to tell
and i said tell tell what he said i'm 13
years old
so for weeks i bought them carton of
cigarettes
every week until finally i ain't doing
this anymore
so a couple months later i got arrested
for that
and spent eight and a half years in
prison
i l not going to say i learned my lesson
because everybody says they learned
their lesson
i know i'm not going to do that again
i'm 74 years old
my sex life is over with i i
i have no feelings for that anymore with
anybody
um i just want to live my life out
and have no more of this
hell because if you go out there
and do something that you shouldn't do
with an underage person
it is hell afterwards
they say well i'd done my time no
you haven't done your time your time
starts after you get out of prison
that's when your time starts and what do
you mean by that
um
i'm in a store if a kid comes up to me
i'm shy away
i shy away because it i don't want
it just it just makes me shy away
it scares me to death
you never know who's watching you
and i just i just shy away
i won't let myself be in that position i
don't think about it you know when a
person
kid comes up to me it just it just
like throws a red flag out they tell you
when you go to group about the red flags
so it just throws up a red flag so i
just
if he says side to me i i gone
but life isn't very hard
when you're banished as a sex offender
or even harder as a sex predator
because once that happens you go in a
neighborhood
and they tell everybody on that street
that they have a sex offender living
there
if you go into an apartment building
they
tell everybody in the apartment building
that there's a sex predator living there
so you're never away from it
i have to register four times a year
with the sheriff's department
and that's no fun because if you forget
you go back to prison and you've got to
do your sentence all over again
your whole complete sentence
so it's it's really
bad to
do a crime and especially when
a murderer is not treated like a sex
offender is treated
and it's to me that's just not right
but to the world it is
i think my mother
sort of screwed my life up because of
the things that happened while i was
laying there
and when my uncle supposedly uncle joe
who she was messing with would spend the
night
at our house i'd get up in the middle of
night
and try to make it with him in a bed i
mean that's all i knew
i thought that was normal you would
initiate
yeah but he pushed me away he didn't
nothing ever happened
he never told my mother but that's what
would happen when he came over
you were home i was six or seven
about that age he he was a custodian
and he had a room with the it's where he
lived he had a room down there with the
big boilers
it was a big building he was custodian
then
i'd say it was about seven or eight
stories big big building
and there were boilers there and my
mother that's where she would go
and have sex with him and it was a small
bed it wasn't a big bed
and i'd be laying right next to my
mother
and they would do the deed
and then i'd try to do the deed when he
came to the house
and i guess that's how i got started
with the boys at school
i would offer them money
tips for my paper route
until i got caught
[Music]
and then we had to move to florida
because my parents were embarrassed
because we have a big family we're
italian
come my mother had eight sisters and one
two brothers
so i had a lot of nephews and nieces and
cousins and we left and nothing happened
till
i ran into this hustler
we were called to clearwater 28
because all 28 of us were with this one
person
and he got picked up for a bne
and the police knew that he was hustling
and he was underage so that's how we all
got
connected with that but your escapade
that you got
arrested for was that one of were there
others that you
engaged in that you didn't get caught
for many
how many young young boys do you think
you had fun with
oh
well there's an note saying as many
dicks they were put in me if they were
sticking out i'd look like a porcupine
that's how many
and
that's no none anymore
yeah the porcupine has died do you
do you have remorse over of that
behavior or
you know
i mean you were you were six seven eight
years old and you were initiating
with older men i mean right i mean maybe
this is a gay culture thing that i don't
i don't understand
it sounds i i don't have any well like
the judge told me with a 13 year old
me buying him cigarettes
he was out there
i didn't give him any money i just did
it because he was cute
but he was out there hustling to
get money for his mother's addiction
that came out in the hearing and the
judge told me that he wasn't going to
charge me any restitution
because i paid my restitution and
garnered cigarettes
but that's the youngest boy that
i went with after i was 30.
30 years old but between the ages of
oh 13 14 and 15
they were young kids from school
but that all ended when i turned 21 and
could get into gay bars
what's the most important lesson you've
learned the important lesson
um
to love myself better
uh to mind my own business
um
i really i guess it's because
i i chalk it up as old age
i guess when you get a certain age you
just don't
care if you have sex anymore i don't
even masturbate anymore
i just friends come in and
i tell them hey since i lived where i'm
living now
we moved in january i'd be a year i
haven't had sex
they'll say yeah we know you but i
haven't
so it's it's just
living out my life
i i want to say though i think about all
these
and i remember all of them
and i think about it it never leaves you
you're always
it's it's in your mind and how how are
those memories for you are they
pleasant are they painful are they do
you have guilt over them do you have
some guilt no no pleasantry
no pleasantry whatsoever not for what i
do you feel like you feel like you took
advantage of these
yeah i do yeah and i did
because at the time they didn't want to
but you work on them
like they say that you you um
prime them so
you get get them to where they they will
do it
yeah i i i
i feel terrible about the whole
situation now that i looked back at it
all those years
i wasted my life and didn't make my life
better at all
and if there's anybody that
does this and is listening to this
and seeing this heath my warning
it's not worth it it really isn't
because you're scarred for life and
thank god my mother's not living
you and your victim both excuse me you
and your victim both
i apologize to my victim 100
times over and if i could
see him i would tell him that i am so
sorry
but we're not allowed to have any
contact with our victims
i wouldn't know where he is anyway
all right frankie thank you so much for
sharing your story oh you're welcome
thank you so much
you